c'est un peu un métier de loup et moi
j'étais un peu déçu de rencontrer des
gens qui quand j'étais de l'autre côté
de la barrière me
fascinai dyslexique une chanson de busie
extraite de son premier 45 tours c'est
ça busie 45 tours dyslexique c'était
c'était le premier 45 tours c'était il y
a 2 ans en 81 voilà alors tu avais fait
des choses auparavant tu chantais non au
niveau de la musique j'avais rien fait
avant j'étais étudiante et je je je
faisais beaucoup de danse c'est mon
premier 45 tours tu es venu pourquoi la
chanson euh qu
motivation je c'est difficile comme
question c'est difficile non je suis
venu par hasard à la chanson parce que
j'ai fait une comédie musicale qui
s'appelit rockyorcha dans lequel je
chantais tout le monde m'a dit bon c'est
bien tu devrais essayer puis bon voilà
je par jeu je me suis mis au piano et
j'ai j'ai composé ça et puis voilà voilà
tu es une formation aussi de musicien
oui j'ai disons que j'ai j'ai des
musiciens dans ma famille quoi bon et ça
t'a aidé donc à me dire est-ce que tu
fais de la scène en ce moment justement
j'ai fait de la scène l'année dernière
sur le 30 et là j'envisage de faire de
la scène très
sérieusement quand mon album va sortir
bon alors donc il y a eu ce premier 45
tours qui s'appelait dyslexique tu
parles d'un album alors ça c'était en
quelle année 82 en 82 j'ai fait un album
qui s'appelait un Somni avec un titre
majeur il s'appelait inrenage qu'on va
pouvoir écouter tout de suite après et
puis bon voilà voilà là j'ai fait un 45
tours et puis je suis en train de
préparer un 30 alors le 45 tours on
l'écoutera après je crois aussi que tu
as changé de maison de disque oui j'ai
changé de maison de disque je suis chez
CBS et bon je suis mieux là-bas que où
j'étais avant bon d'accord merci pour
eux est-ce que est-ce que tu as une
démarcheentend bien est-ce que tu as une
démarche féministe absolument pas je
suis absolument pas féministe en quoi
que ce soit même quand je chante une
chanson comme adrénaline je n'ai rien
contre les mecs je les adore surtout
quand ils ont des fouls roses autour du
cou un détail c'est qui qui a signé la
pochette c'est jean-baptis Mino qui a
signé la pochette qui a signé aussi la
dernière pochette de quelqu'un que tu
adores oui alin Bassou qui qui était
venu dans roing share alors justement
bon tu tu me racontais une anecdote dans
ce métier finalement tous les gens
connus sont pas toujours très très
agréables à rencontrer quand on débute
c'est un peu un métier de loup et moi
j'étéis un peu déçu de rencontrer des
gens qui quand j'étais de l'autre côté
de la barrière me fascinait mais j'ai
rencontré aussi des gens qui qui me qui
me sont fort sympathiques comme alin
Bachou par exemple tu nous donnes
l'anecdote bah l'anecdote c'est que je
je n'ai jamais rencontré alin Bachou
alors que j'ai rencontré à peu près
Prati tout le monde dans ce métier et
j'ai fait jean-l Fouquier il y a 15
jours il écoutait l'émission il m'a
téléphoné et j'ai trouvé ça très très
gentil on lui dira à Bachou quand il
reviend rendre King cher Fouquier qui
bosse sur Radio francein est quelqu'un
qui t'a aidé à tes débuts oui m' il m'a
soutenu c'est il m'a beaucoup soutenu
sur le 30 sur voilà il t' aidé parce que
tu étais une chanteuse française je veux
dire parce que tu d'expression française
mais je veux dire c'est la chanson
française qui t'intéresse ou est-ce que
quelque part le rock parce que tes
chansons sont rock aussi tintéress
inéress
il y a une différence là pour toi où il
y a pas de barrière pour moi il y a pas
de barrière le rock ce qui m'intéresse
c'est la musique c'est ni le rock ni la
variété ni la chanson française ni
j'aime la musique donc mais pourtant tu
as cette image là quand même un peu tu
as une image rock j'ai une image rock
parce que d'abord ça vient de mon
physique je pense que je suis habillée
toujours d'une façon un peu décontractée
donc je peux difficilement
avoir une image de de de minette ou de
quelqu'un de sophistiqué et puis aussi
parce que ce que je fais c'est à
électrique mais ça ça vient de ma
génération je je fais aussi des balades
très douces alors ça c'est le dernier 45
tours c'est ce qu'on va écouter
maintenant c'est adrénaline c'est le
titre fort de l'autre côté il y a une
chanson plus douce oui une chanson très
douce qui s'appelle bleu mais tu fais
aussi des chansons je veux dire tu ça
c'est une une question de personnalité
c'est j'ai un peu double facette je suis
aussi violente et agressive que je peux
être tendre et gentille alors ça raconte
quoi adrénaline un peu
adrénaline c'est l'histoire de d'une
fille qui qui s'énerve qui se fait un
peu draguer par par par des mecs quoi
des mecs un peu stéréotypés mais j'ai
rien sinon contre les
mecs mais là c'est bon c'est c'est une
petite anecdote c'est l'histoire de de
d'une nana qui se fait draguer dans une
boîte voilà d'accord je te remercie
d'être venu dans rocking chir à bientôt
à bientôt je vous remercie beaucoup
aussi